[Applaudissements]
alors
alésien installez vous voilà jean messia
est arrivé et gucci aussi ensuite qu'on
comprenne bien histoire donc voilà ça
démarre par des affrontements le calme
semblait être revenu mais ce samedi une
centaine de personnes se sont retrouvées
devant la mairie à l'appel de la ligue
de défense noire africaine pour
protester certaines d'entre elles ont
donc réussi à pénétrer dans l'instance
interpharma et le maire sur le parvis
qui a malgré tout conservé son calme
regardez et c'est vrai que c'était
panique générale à la mairie regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on assure celle aussi pour
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai que tout mandat ravi
parce qu'ils avaient des mariages à la
mairie voilà et gucci merci d'être avec
nous merci jean messia
également alors c'est vrai que beaucoup
de gens ont réagi et c'est vrai que il
ya beaucoup d'enfants qui ont dit c'est
vrai qu'il y avait des gens qui se
marier et c est derrière marine le pen a
pris a pris à des affrontements
intercommunautaires à val de reuil en
normandie mais qui veut de cette france
du chaos et du communautarisme dans
laquelle nous mène tout droit à la
politique de macron il faut d'urgence
remettre la france en dents mal à mlp et
c'est vrai que derrière gérald darmanin
a décidé lancer la procédure engageant
donc la dissolution de la ligue de
défense la dna et gucci benzinou êtes le
fondateur
qu'est ce que vous m'envoyez ces images
vous cautionnez ou pas quand je vois les
moches de l'enfant village oui sans plus
sans plus à lire c'est à dire je sais
pas si je savoure sa vous désole parce
qu'il ya des gens qui se mariait tous
acquis à leur mariage est peut être
cachée ou pas du que les gens se marient
wissing peut-être mais que le maire soit
en farine et bon jeu ça ne me touche pas
pour ce que ça pourquoi je sais pas allé
demander à les poser la question à la
personne qui à
l'auteur de l'an farine âge ne soit pas
vous n'avez rien à voir la tension en
attendant jusqu'à présent il ya beaucoup
de discours mais très peu de profondeur
alors la mairie s'est fait envahir
ensuite une quarantaine de personnes a
investi le bâtiment et monte à l'état
joue trois mariages se tenait il ya
beaucoup de mariages dans cette mairie
orange
des halles mairie veut lui faire le mal
alors
on aimerait que vous réagissiez là
dessus et sur la prise de parole de
gérald darmanin pour vous alors pour
commencer j'aimerais dire il ya un
proverbe aux béninois qui dit le soleil
levé ne peut se cacher d'accord ça veut
dire que dharmanand c'est un démagogue
c'est un démagogue pensée qui j'aimerais
voir par quel acrobatique
juridique il pourra nous dissoudre et
s'il arrive je suis prêt à l'inviter à
prendre dans le vert au salon chez moi
alors cette décision était prescrit les
experts intervenus ce week-end oui pour
vous il ya aucune raison de dissoudre
votre vie vous savez c'est tout
simplement et purement une décision
politique parce que la ligue de défense
nord africaine dérange l'état négrier
français en colonialiste esclavagiste et
terroristes donc ce n'est pas la
première fois et on sait que derrière la
tacc demandant pour dissoudre la ligue
de défense nord africaine s'il parvient
bien évidemment à réussir c'est une
attaque personnelle contre ma personne
parce que je dérange par nos actions et
parents mes propos et mes prises de
position alors l'état français c'est pas
la première fois que le mouvement fait
parler de lui ces derniers mois il a
notamment été à l'initiative de
plusieurs manifestations
22000 19 de ses militants avaient en
outre été condamnée pour avoir intimité
patrick balkany en pleine rue qu'est ce
que vous dites qu'est ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
le qu'est ce que dit gérald darmanin
pour vous dissoudre elles sont ces
scénarii c'est pour ça que je vous dise
est un démagogue il n'est il ne il veut
juste séduire au fait les français parce
qu'on sait que
l'élection présidentielle approche donc
darmana fait le cerneux vous pas
forcément de moi mais de patron pour
séduire les français personnes qui vous
suivent un sur notre page facebook plus
de 300 on est suivie en temps par plus
d'un million de personnes sur nos
réseaux et nous sommes vus
nos vidéos nos actions sont vus par le
gouvernement dise que vous avez des
valeurs et qui parfois vous ça pouvait
être violent vous pouvez voir des
méthodes un peu particulières suite mais
il dit que nous sommes une structure
raciste mais c'est ça venant d'une
personne qui tient des propos
négrophobes et non et raciste et
j'aimerais bien qu'ils pussent nous
démontrer qu'il nous fasse la
démonstration
et quand quoi nous sommes racistes a en
deux les caveaux des viols en réel à l
adema location on l'a eue là la
démonstration dans la mairie nous
serions nous sommes violent si on était
violent je ne serais pas là à côté de
vous pourquoi parce que je suis pas
violent mais ménagez vous appelez par
violon vous êtes rentré dans une mairie
avait un mariage vous avez frappé
la suisse et comment elle a trois jours
d'itt et ça elle attendait à temps elle
a trois jours disputée attendez attendez
qu'elle a trois jours d'itt et dont elle
serait la meilleure formation dont
monsieur accord je ne tolère à l'arrêt
l'information vous dites qu'on a frappé
vous m'avez vu frapper une dame et je ne
parle pas de voix dans des clients alors
que les kings mais c'est pas mon groupe
c'est vous qui les ont reçus mais c'est
pas mal on parle mais personne ne met
moins bien votre niche on saisit mal à
personne le démontre sur ces images
quelle personne de la ldn on a fait quoi
que ce soit pour moi c'est pas quelqu'un
de votre ligue a frappé qui
ne lui ont dit et et le choeur bousculer
classé rétais police municipale regardez
puisqu'elle a alors
qu'il le tue regardez on le connaît pas
regardez les empêcher d'entrer en salle
du conseil ils ont donc dégonder la
porte de la salle de conseil qui l'ont
complètement arrachée et qui est tombé
au sol en ce qu'ils sont pénétré dans la
salle des mariages où le maire était en
train de célébrer le mariage les enfants
se sont mis à hurler des femmes ont fait
effectivement des malaises le couloir
était à ce sujet dans un couloir de 10 m
sur 1 m nous étions une trentaine en
train d'essayer de les bloquer de les
freiner pour les empêcher de tous entrés
en force dans la salle du conseil pour
demander audience au maire pendant qu'il
célébrer un mariage c'est ça leur
méthode mais alors là où elle a été
agressée alors si le mr le maire jean en
mai que cet élu a été molesté mais on ne
nous montre pas vous savez vous pouvez
aller sur nos pas aimé vous attendez ce
qu'il a dit est allé sur nos pages les
vidéos si je veux condamner cet accord
pas parce que les vidéos sont
disponibles moule qu'on est ce que elle
elle condamne le fait que des kurdes du
pkk
soutenu par le maire de sa ville parce
que le maire de la ville est tenu par la
communauté kurde hamas qu'ils sont
partis manifester dans la ville en dix
ans ils sont où les noirs nous sommes
venus tuer des noirs et dans cette
galerie est donc adoptée mais l'employé
mais les personnes à condamner sur la
hausse a jamais personne n'a dit cela à
personne si vous savez la femme du petit
garçon d'origine africaine agressé c'est
une française et quand elle se faisait
tabasser les kurdes étaient en train de
le dire salles françaises salles
françaises ils ont dénudé elle a été
dénudée on n'a pas vu dharmanand
s'exprimer là dessus le fait que un
groupe de personnes encadrées soutenu en
plus parler la ville encadrés par les
crs qui n'ont même pas arrêté qu'il se
soit disloqué nous sommes là pour ça au
fait et guti on vous donne souvent la
parole dans cette émission parce que
nous on en a parlé à tout le monde on a
envie d'avoir les tenants et les
aboutissants réels de chaque histoire là
sur cette affaire si vous me dites si ce
que vous dites est vrai c'est bien sûr
inadmissible et on ne cautionne pas du
tout ce que vous avez les vidéos mais
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est la
bonne ou une solution aussi d'aller
investir la mairie parce que même pour
vous je pense que c'est contreproductif
vous ne pensez vous pensez que ça c'est
nous on assume mexes et si la justice le
cosplay bonne part mais voilà aux portes
vous savez si la justice nous sommes
disposés si la justice nous convoque on
répondra pour le moment et à l'en farine
âge mais ça a déjà commencé depuis le
montant là vous montrer qu'une partie de
la vidéo les jeux vous me le maire a
tenu des propos envers les manifestants
quand il sortait de la mairie en disant
ils sont encore là les chiens à les
noirs vous ne m'impressione pas qu'il
finit par se faire enfermer et vous êtes
en train de me demander ce que je pense
six années des vidéos oui et tu voulais
aussi montrer deux extraits vidéo parce
qu'on parle beaucoup des mariés mais les
moyens nous ont soutenus qui pour toi
montrent ce que vous vivez au quotidien
on regarde la vidéo tueur il explique ce
qui s'y passe regarde
et vous tu l'as mérité d'accord
codifié pour profonde et armés ils sont
bien ces sites est battu
[Musique]
sikimic gaz lacrymogènes
enfin pas rester dans le monde du hockey
je vous préviens
alors c'est quoi them on dit rien ce que
vous jouez en fait ce sont les membres
les milices du pkk 300 personnes c'est
quoi c'est le pk tu as et une
organisation terroriste ont classé
terroriste dans le monde en ce n'est pas
je ne vais pas vous apprendre c'est la
chose qui manifestent à tuer sont venus
sans autorisation que vous voyez encadré
vous voyez que les crs sont là ces
personnes tiennent des propos ils sont
tous à renée 30 armes ont été récupérées
sur veut 0 interpellation les gones qui
jettent sur lui comme je vous dis moi je
comprends tout à fait voilà que vous
puissiez avoir quelques griefs contre
ces personnes et si ce que vous dites
est vrai et on va le vérifier très vite
taillables voilà bien sûr que c'est tout
à fait condamnable mais je vous dis je
pense que le fait d'avoir été dans la
mairie je pense c'est une erreur parce
que c'est une erreur de communication
parce que les gens vont se dire après
c'est eux voilà qui foutent la discorde
alors que ça parte et peut-être d'un bon
sentiment si vous en pensez chine ses
recherches mais oui mais même les gens
qui comme moi trouve que vos
problématiques sont intéressantes vous
menez les actions intéressantes là vous
nous rejeter vous dégoûter parce que
franchement vous cautionnez vous êtes
très ambigu là ce soir je suis très
honoré ben oui vous cautionnez la
violence ou non je ne concerne pas la
violence nos produits je ne sais qu'ils
ont trop fait et je ne cochez là c'est
pas possible je ne cautionne pas la
violence gratuite non non je ne
cautionne pas la violence gratuite mais
ce que moi je ne cautionne pas c'est le
fait que dans la ville des personnes ont
été agressées uniquement sur leur avenir
demain agression vidanger
soi-même sur cela parce que la vessie
vous parlez mais pour le moment on ne
sait toujours pas qui a fait quoi
c'est pas la principale qui rentrait
dans le hall de la mairie rentrer dans
une mairie elle était la mairie elle
était ouverte c'est un lieu plus
je condamne et condamné quoi
pour aller fêter le mariage mais
attendez guy la mairie la mairie
s'arrête jamais et vous aimez les
autorités de la ville ouvert à l'arrière
ils savaient qu'ils avaient un
rassemblement samedi tout le monde le
savait d'accord il y avait le
commissaire départemental qui était là
il y avait les policiers elle à la
police nationale la police municipale
donc s'il y avait des infractions on
aurait pu être à réserver des zones est
d'accord il est des gens c'est ça laisse
la porte je vais vous dire le problème
des dégradés par l'agent de sécurité
ramené par le maire et nous avons les
images c'est l'agent de sécurité ramener
qui travaille au jardin d' acclimatation
à paris lahlou les messieurs c'est un
président qui ont arraché à l'invention
ce n'est pas nous et gucci il n'y avait
aucune arrestation il ya aucune
arrestation nous sommes même parti on a
salué le commissaire nous avons des
vidéos on a discuté avec le commissaire
nous sommes repartis comme nous sommes
venus et je vous dis par contre par
contre le maire il a agressé il a
dégradé nos matériels et nous avons il y
a deux plaintes qui sont déposées contre
monsieur le maire et je peux vous le
démontrer que contrairement à ce qu'il
dit les plaintes au sont là d'accord il
ya plusieurs plaintes qui sont déposées
contre monsieur le maire pour violences
et dégradations
et ça personne n'en parle mais là on
nous dit
vous avez vous en parlait ici un jour
mais c est quand vous entendez la
version 2d gucci
écoutez moi je sais pas exactement ce
qui s'est passé tout ce que j'ai vu
c'est effectivement des militants de la
ldn à envahir violemment la mairie
bousculer les gens interrompre des
mariages bon c'est pas des méthodes de
personnes civilisées des d'action
civilisé ce qui n'était guère étonnant
mais par delà cette qu'elle est
problématique de le dieu de val de reuil
il ya tout le tout l'action de la ld n'a
depuis des mois et des années on n'a pas
les leurs
cependant juste pour dire qu'une chose
le maire a quand même avoué ce week-end
notamment sur ses doutes que la
communauté kurde dont il parle aussi
voilà on sait pas ce qui s'est passé
mais avait tenu aussi des propos
racistes contre eux parce que nous
sommes entre les mains des lamentations
vous savez ce qu'il a dit monsieur le
maire fait dans les kurdes étaient en
train d'attaquer les habitants les
personnes d'origine africaine dans la
ville il est parti dire ou aux kurdes
c'est bon maintenant partez j'ai tenu la
parole attendait mais elle a tenu la
parole sur scène parce que deux frères
estime en face nos frères sont j'ai des
raisons à la base c'était eux les
victimes c'est eux qui se retrouve en
prison et les agresseurs sont en liberté
zéro arrestation à l'heure où je vous
parle un frère hibou se trouve en prison
le père de famille qu'est parti défendre
sa femme et son fils agressés par les
kurdes il se trouve en prison et
personnes de la communauté demandent
pourquoi jouer quatre là présent ce soir
au collège et donc et c'est ça que nous
nous condamnons fermement c'est un oui
non mais attendez moi les gens si vous
voulez qu'ils ont des propos antisémites
qui sont des races je vous invite à
faire la demande et racialiste je vous
invite encore une fois c'était pour
obliger de vendre des flics vous claveau
claquer des fesses devant les juifs 1 au
nom
des spéciales quand vous dites ou format
c'est moi finir je vous ai laissé parler
c'est votre nationalité dans un finish
public on n'est pas la présidence a une
chambre avec mario la marionnette nous
sommes en pourparlers
vous êtes sûre si ces mythes se fout des
traces et je ne peux pas les
gros fonds et vous devez mentionner
soudure ça
gergorin se sont sacrifiés gérald a
trouvé le mort est un mort et six autres
en deux temps trois mouvements les
identitaires du rachis des identitaires
comme vous ou les suprémacistes noir je
ne suis le réseau twitter qu'il reste à
ce gouvernement je vais je vous dise
vous est temps
d'aller acheter en dévidant des
commerces chinois dans les commerces qui
sont autre que des noirs longs nez voilà
pourquoi bien
sujet on a déjà parlé de tout ça faisait
bizarre mais c'est will je veux juste
que je sais
c'est
la strate je n'avais ni tanière oui
quand il ya des gros faux billets
antisémitisme milliards à 6 oui là on
est d'accord on est d'accord mais on
n'est pas là pour parler de ça pendant
le bien c'est important de le dire vous
savez la lance qui était stationné
monsieur je ne peux pas l'être parce que
moi mon grand père mon grand père est
mort en protégeant les juifs dans ce
pays d'accord la or la plupart des
français collaborait alors peut nier
l'existence tu peux nier le fait que la
france a collaboré pour exterminer les
juifs ici sur ce plateau le recensement
mais pour nous on fait qu'elle a fondée
pour nier que la france a labouré pour
exterminer le peuple africain et la
séance pour français mais les appliquant
pas de bon sens on ne peut
comprendre sa ville et ont massacré
l'hymne la bête et des droits je vous
avais à dire à gérald darmanin ce soir
ce que j'ai à dire à monsieur darmanin
je comprends que dharmanand que
politiquement parlant nous dérangeons
dharmanand et je vais vous dire une
chose je sais que ma compo léon d'accord
mais sur ma compo leon panetta bien a
volé en nous le dérange énormément parce
que tellement qu'on le dérange je vais
vous dire une chose si on était comme
eux quand messieurs mâcon paul et on
nous a envoyé ses sbires députés pour
venir nous voir a dit qu'on essaierait
de parler avec nous qu'on a refusé c'est
tout à fait normal qu'aujourd'hui on
devient l'ennemi à abattre un de ce
gouvernement aujourd'hui qui oppriment
même le premier français qui peut nier
le fait que d'évidence et parlait jamais
fait une équipe à ce que ma comptes
donne l'autorisation à la à des gens de
les tuer c'est ça aujourd'hui qui
déroule un trip c'est aussi sa politique
érige la fonte l'état français je ne
parle pas de l'ensemble des français
mais l'état français c'est notre message
à gérald darmanin ça soit le message que
j'ai à dire radar maintenant je répète
encore une fois je l'invite à faire la
démonstration acrobatique juridiquement
parlant pour nous expliquer en quoi il
peut me dissoudre c'est tout d'accord on
a connu en une minute en une minute
monsieur et gucci béhanzin et est
vraiment le fils naturel de toutes ces
politiques folle d'immigration et de
naturalisation qui font qu'un type qui a
été oui qui condamne et non non non
écouter qui passe sa vie à le chercher
sur la france non non non je n'essaie de
la france
je vous dis
rien sur les salaires je crache sur le
système
sur le système de jeu c'est un coup de
sortir dont je vous avais dit
vous virer de la baignoire et 9h mais la
france nous allons terminer sur plaisir
de terminer les deux là la hache on sait
pas bien ce que vous dites à une gucci
franchement mais attendez
succès comment prendre c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est vous qui êtes un trader
si vous êtes français vous êtes
d'horizon est certaine il vous donnera
quelques années vous vous
débarrassez si je suis dans le
sachet une histoire il faut être à
la bassée c'est un jeune sénégalais qui
a défendu son fils qui s'était pris une
baffe voilà par un kurde et les
rhumatismes crânien et et voilà et il a
envoyé le cuir d'hôpital il était boxeur
est pourquoi on ne montre pas la vidéo
des mariés c'est ça qui nous soutiennent
qu'ils soutiennent l'action que nous
avons menée à écouter ou là on loue la
salle existeront là on a tout envoyé
la vidéo et bombe à la montre est bas
alors montré la vidéo alors balattou tu
peux pas